[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, the
weekly podcast where we exchange
ideas about content we've read, listened to, and
watched, always bringing a
product/PR discussion perspective. I'm Artur, after
three
weeks there won't be any more courses this
weekend. I'm
also looking forward to not having given a few weeks of courses.
In
today's program, we're going to talk about
a single topic:
critical and analytical thinking. What a
convenient topic, right Artur? Because what
was the last course in the
Arena? It might even seem like a plug
here, right? Getting into the plug, but anyway,
the week of the sequence of
three consecutive weekends with
courses is over. Now we'll have
another round at the end of June and July, it
will also be a few weeks,
two weeks straight. But
before talking about the plug here, I wanted to share what
the people who participated
in the last critical and analytical thinking course
said. Andressa Ribeiro, who is a
Senior PM at RD Station, said one day that she did
n't even feel the time pass, super
rich content.  It's real and necessary, and Line, who is a
Senior PM at Food, said it was a day of
great learning. I didn't know I
needed this course so much until I took it. Anyway, so, as the
participants themselves said,
we're going to have two more rounds of the critical
analytical thinking course. On June
29th, it will be live online. So, for those of
you who are outside of São Paulo or who ca
n't attend in person, even if you're
in São Paulo on June 29th, there's also another one on July 6th, which
will be in person at our office at
Juus. So that's it. And
also, if you think that's all, it's not. On July
20th, known as July, right? Saturday in
July, there will be another edition of the course
for PMs, the third edition. Ikira
will also be there talking about the GP chat,
the GP she did, and we'll have several other
things too. The link is in the
description with that awesome discount
as always. Now, let's go to
the...
[Music] So,
this block... I know it
sounds a bit like a plug here, but it's...  Seriously,
he's genuinely discussing this because
after we did these last few
episodes and with the various feedback
we received, we saw that this whole thing about
critical and analytical thinking, about
connecting the changes you make to the
product with the
company's financial indicators and everything else, isn't
discussed as much as it should be. And since it's a topic that Ikira and I
always talk
about whenever we can, I was going to say this, right? It's not like
we've never talked about this on
the podcast before the courses, right? Well,
we wanted to bring it up to discuss a
little more with
our dear
listeners. So, to start,
what is this thing called critical and
analytical thinking? I'll paraphrase Dudu,
my partner from the course, who has
also appeared on the podcast talking
about Proops,
but his phrase for it is the
ability to evaluate a problem
by examining facts and information that
strengthen or invalidate a logical point of
view, considering
cause-and-
effect relationships. That sounds pretty
deep to me. Dudu has a gift for
words,
but...  So, how do you explain
what critical and analytical thinking is?
I lack the gift of
gab, like Dudu, you know?
[Music] I
think the way I think about
it is that the two
concepts of criticism and analysis are quite separate.
But first, thinking
critically is about removing biases, being
able to look at a problem and
see it in its smallest form, you know,
reducing the problem to the maximum and
removing all the elements so that
you
can understand what it is, what it boils down to,
right? So you understand
the problem in fact and not what you think
of the problem, what another person thinks, or
what all the components of the world
made this problem appear. And then the
analytical part of it, when we
talk about being analytical, many people
immediately think of
quantitative analysis, right? And I think it's about
that too, but it's about thinking:
What are the things you
need to analyze in order to understand
that problem, to understand
its size, to understand possibilities? And then it
goes a lot into that thing we
always talk about here: how you break down a
problem and how you solve
its parts.  The problem identifies the root cause of
that problem through this breakdown, right?
So how do you make a big business
smaller by looking at it
critically? How do you understand these
smaller parts, analyzing them in a
more... well, a little
less summarized than the previous explanation,
but it's a little bit the way I see it.
I think it has a lot to do with
several things we talk about here regarding
problem-solving
and other things. It even reminded me a
little of the book "Thinking
Bad," right? I was thinking about
it because it talks a lot about
removing biases, especially
when discussing with other people. And
when we're talking about
critical thinking, it's this: how do you
raise arguments for
and against based on points of
view or information you have? This
is an exercise I always like to do, which even gets
a little into
the line of risk assessment from Keanu or things like that,
but I always like to do it right away.
Okay, there's a thing, so
in my best-case scenario, how could it be in
my worst-case scenario?  How can it be, and what if
possible things can happen? So
when something happens, right? That's what's going to happen,
but also in
decision-making, using these factors a little bit,
right? Like, okay? What are the
things in favor of this, and what are the
things against it in relation to this point?
So, as simple as opening a slide and
throwing these little boxes at it: Okay, it
could go wrong, it could go good, okay?
And if it goes wrong, how much are we
willing to accept for the bad, or what? What isn't, right? And
everything else, and then
we get into the
analytical part of things. It's very much about how
we collect the facts and
put the logical thing there, right? In the
discussion, it even enters
into what you might sometimes think of as something non-
analytical, but in storytelling, right? What
story are you trying to tell? Or
what are you thinking here? What are the
facts that support it? And the thing
we didn't talk about, which
also relates to the book you mentioned, is:
what premises exist, or what forces
are acting within this that
could modify
reality, right? Because the book talks a lot
about poker, right? So that's a good example.
Sometimes you have a
play that's
statistically correct considering all the factors,
but imagine you're playing
a hand and if you lose, you don't win the
money in that tournament, which is when
the prize money starts.
And it's very important to win
the money in that tournament; it's
the difference between being able to play
another tournament or not.
Sometimes in that case, it's better to make the
decision that's statistically wrong
because in that specific situation there are
other factors that exert a
greater force on that decision.
So, it's a bit about what premises exist
here to be considered.
And thinking about that, when you think
you started developing this,
bringing the
perspective of someone who's been
in the market for a long time, what I
see today is that I say, "Wow, this should
be a
basic skill." I'm
talking about today, in my position with
many years of experience and everything else, I
look back and say, "Wow, this is
a basic skill." And that's what I try to
strengthen in my teams, structuring
them so they always have this in their essence. A
large part of the teams I've built have
always been...  With that as a basis, but I know
that while teaching, we're realizing
that it's not a skill that people have
very developed, and then I stopped to
ask myself, when did
I make that switch? I
started analyzing this and how it
became part of my DNA, you know? But before I
tell you, I wanted to know how
you started developing this. I'm
quite clear that it was in a much
more senior phase of my career, much
more recently than at the beginning.
Going back a few steps, I
started my career in data, so
this
more analytical part, and
especially the quantitative part, I think
my background helped. So again,
dividing it into two parts, between the
critical part and the analytical part, I think
I had one more developed, but
I still developed it more later, you
know? I had a part of it. And just to
add a parenthesis to what you're
saying, the data part helped you to
be more
analytical. But one thing I see
particularly
in people who already have a
very technical background with a lot of data is that
they have a very highly
developed analytical part, but the critical part is very low,
and then the balance becomes very...  It's
unequal because then it's not even
data-driven, it's data-only, you know, it's
data-only. And I think that's why
I ended up going
into product, because it's that thing where
data alone is useless if
you're not connecting it to the
business, if you're not getting insights
from it, right? So I think I was
able to process that in
product. Now you're going to say that
you went into product the other day, you
said you supported me when I
went to the United States, now you're
going to say that you went into
product because of me, you had
influence, you had information, you had
influence, but you had that, right? But I
feel that both things together, I
started to develop more when I already
had a PM position,
thinking about the job itself, and for me it's
very clear that I thought I was a person
who was good at solving problems, I
solved problems at work and so on,
but I didn't know how to do it in a
structured way, so I didn't have a
clear process for that. I think the moment it
clicked for me, like, 'Damn, I have to
develop this,'
changed my way of thinking.  I
think that's pretty much what you're
saying. You went back to think about it
when you started to give more
importance to understanding it
as a fundamental skill. That's when
I thought, "
Okay, now I need to learn how to
solve problems in a structured way."
And it was even a... a former leader of
mine, Alice, whom we've already talked about,
and whom we need to call Alice PR PR,
and I think it's very curious that it's
something very natural for someone who has a
career in consulting, like
BCG and all that. People like to make fun of
consultants a lot, right? But the consultant's job
is to solve problems in a
structured way and know how to put that into a...
a format and apply it. And
I think that was the driver, like, "Okay,
now I have to
learn how to do this in a
structured way," and I learned that was the click.
And for me, it's like you said, since then
I've been saying, "Man, this is a
fundamental product skill, it's
something that should be taught from the beginning,"
and I think there's even a gap in
product education, in talking too little
about it, you know?  Let's talk more about other
things, but how did that happen with
PR Carena? That's it, man, that's it. But
man, uh, I think context, right?
I had an agency when I was at the
beginning of my career. I was an
industrial cost engineer, even while studying Business Administration. So, even
before
thinking about working with product, I
was already making these connections,
these causal relationships, like how much what
I'm doing can
impact, how much it's
financially connected, and what it can
become later, right? So,
looking back today, that's it. I
was already kind of
indirectly triggering this from early on. But for me, I think
the big point was having worked
in an e-commerce company, and that was
one of the big leaps of faith
when we started to grow. It was, man,
talking about 2014
when buying through apps wasn't
business like we do today, right?
And then we managed to make a
connection between how much
crash-free we got and how much we
shared, how much we sold.
Literally, you know, and it might seem super
simple like that, but it was a trick that turned into something
that popped into my
head. Like, if we can
do this, we should look
at anything else too, how
much we make
that connection. And now, to make a
parenthesis here, of course, it won't always make sense to
do this 100% of the time, but when you
start to exercise this and
have this critical and
analytical perspective, you'll be able to do it. Okay, this
makes sense. I'll
delve a little deeper and make this
connection, this other thing here.
I think the little key you use is to understand
everything, like systems that have inputs,
processing, and outputs, and
levers. So, to manipulate this, I
have this lever here that I can
pull to one side or the other, right? And in the
end, you can take several problems
and reduce them to this: understand what
the levers of this system are,
what the levers are, how this
system works in general, and the
world is systems, right? And I'm not
talking about technological systems here, but
systems in a more general way.
So, what are the levers that
move this point? And you mentioned
systems, another thing
I talk about a lot in relation to this is that
everything is a funnel, and it's along the same
lines as you're talking about systems, because
everything has a beginning, a number of
people or things happening that
go through a series of stages, and in the
end you'll have the result,
which is how many reached the end, or
executed until the end, or it was done until
the end, right? So with that, you can
connect things much more and make
all of this create the system in the end,
right? And this is applicable
to me looking for an apartment, right?
Looking for an apartment is a funnel; I
have to look at so many apartments, of those I look at, I
'll like so many, of those
I like, I
'll send messages to so many, I'll
visit so many, to send proposals to so many
to close one. So you have to
do this calculation, right? Okay, and
now, changing the topic a bit,
how do
you see that a person is
being good at this, or is, or is at least
going in the right direction, is starting?
Man, I think
this question of you  What I call breaking down the
problem, for me, is the way to
understand and train, let's say, is to
take a problem
that I have to solve. So, what is it
normally in our daily
work? What metric do I
have to adjust? What is the
master metric here? And sometimes this problem,
this breakdown, will start at the top, where
you have the company's metric, and you have to
understand what the breakdown of that
metric is for your team. Sometimes it's not,
sometimes it's already given, look, your team
is around this little number here, and you
understand it. But I think what tells me a lot,
and even the way I try to
learn, is this: how you take a
result, a problem you have to solve, and
you do this breakdown.
And it's a somewhat complicated thing to
learn, not to train, let's
say, because there's no answer key, right? It
's not a mathematical calculation where you go
there and have to give a five at the end. There's a
bit of flaw in the evaluation itself, right?
So sometimes you're tackling a
problem for the first time, you don't
understand its levers so well, you
have to break it down. You won't have it right away.
A vision like this, damn, this problem,
it's Miss, for example, you know, I took
all the elements, these elements don't
overlap with each other, but over time,
as you see the same problem
again and again, or as you gain more
depth, you go back and
solve it, incorporating the things
you learned
in your initial assessment. I think
this
ability, this ability to break down
and
correct things with the things
you've learned over time, makes it
much easier to build
the systems later, you'll already have
your systems much clearer,
to start structuring
critical and analytical thinking. In the
end, and I think at this
stage the analytical part comes in a lot, right?
If you're breaking down this
problem, how do you compare these
things? How do you say, "Hey,
I'm comparing apples to apples,
so I can say that this is
an opportunity, a leverage of X
million, and this one is X million
minus one," and maybe it makes more sense to
attack this X million one, you know? You
start thinking, how do
I know what's
inside here, you know, what...  What are the values
of this? And then start making these
connections, even with the elements of the business
itself. That's what you've already ended up
fitting into... actually, before we
asked here how to know if a
person is minimally understanding this,
so you talked about breaking down and seeing
how the person is breaking down the
problems, also how we
provoke, right? Speaking here as
leaders, as managers and everything
else, how do we make the
right provocations to create the systems
as well? But how do you see that it's
possible to train this? You even said, "
Wow, it's kind of complicated," but
how do you see that it's possible to give
this seed for people to
start exploring this, even if they can't
necessarily apply it,
like on day zero in their company? I
think for me it's a curiosity about
business,
and it's business in depth, it's
taking a business and understanding how it
works, how it makes money, what
its costs are, what are fixed costs,
what are variable costs, how do these
things relate, until you have an
interest in business, and that's a bit of
what we do here, right? When
we recommend content, I think it's a...  A
little bit of that curiosity we
also have about not only products, but
technology and business as a whole, and I think that's
it. And then I have a little something from the
time I had to learn problem-
solving, and I think the
closest thing you
can use online to practice is business cases.
So, you take cases—
traditionally MBA cases, which
are, in the end, business breakdowns—so that
's basically it. I think that
helps you understand how a
business works and what the levers are, so
when
you have to do one on your own,
you have the repertoire to say, "
Wow, this is similar to this other
thing," or "This is exactly the same as this
other thing." I was explaining the "Day
D" work on how to break down a
subscription business because a
subscription business is basically a
lifetime business, and lifetime... there
are only two ways to increase it: either you
increase the lifetime or you
increase the old... and then you break it down. So what
's inside lifetime? Ah, this, this, this... what's
inside
old... is  So, that's it. And then at the end I
told the person and said, "From now on, for the
rest of your life, this is how
you break any
subscription business, regardless of what it is, you know?"
So the basic structure
of a subscription product is this, but
why do I know this? Because I've worked with
a lot of subscription products in my
life and gained experience from that. To
face a problem I've never seen before, something
very different, I won't have
the experience yet. So I think this
consumption of businesses is what will
give you that experience so that when
you find yourself in a situation, you have
at least a path to follow, you
know? Uh-huh, okay. So I think there are some
tips here, like how I train my
curiosity about businesses,
definitely that's it, understanding and stuff. And
there's another tip that we talk about in more
detail in the course. So, for example,
doing DM exercises, right?
That's it. You can ask the
GPT chat there and stuff, but we talk more about
that in the course. And then you got
hooked, I was going to talk about the GPT chat,
but you said because it can be a
partner.  So, for him to evaluate
you, to do a Business Case together with
him, to evaluate you, it might not be the
most precise thing in the world, but he will
help guide you there, you know,
definitely. And then you've already connected
with another block, with another thing,
which, let's say, is ISO, right? It's
curiosity about business, which is what
I've been saying for a long time: when you
enter a company, the
first thing is how does this
company make money? How does the wheel
turn? How does it make money?
How does it lose money? What are the theses?
Who's doing what, how are they doing it? How do
competitors do it?
Like, companies that do the same or
similar thing outside of Brazil or in
other markets do it? So, subscribing
to the newsletters of those who cover this market
you're entering are all ways
for you before you start the tactical phase,
right? Because with that, you'll know, it
will help you even when making
decisions, right? Does it make sense to delve deeper into this
or not? Is this a
differentiator or is this a commodity?
So I think there are several of these things,
and then another...  The point is, if
you know what your team needs to
do, you're on par with the rest of the market. It's the bare minimum you
need to do. If you
know how your team's actions
impact the company's business,
you're already, I'd say, about 50%
ahead of most
PMs (I'm exaggerating). And if you know how
the company as a whole works, how the
market as a whole works, the
market you're
in, you're, I'd say,
about
90% ahead of the obvious, you know?
I was muted here, but when
you said 50%, you were exaggerating. I
think you're even pulling it down,
really.
For me, it's 90% in both cases. But I,
and Igor, who is the CEO of PIAA (I
worked there for a while), had a
phrase he told me once that
I always remember: "At the Limit," each
product initiative, each
product objective, should be connected to a
line in the company's P&L. So you, as a
PM, should know how to explain and make those
upward connections.  How does that
thing you're doing relate to the
company's profit and loss statement? You know, in the end, it's how
you're looking at the business, right? Like in
a publicly traded company,
what investors are looking at at the
end of the day is the accounting, the profit and loss statement,
the top line, the online bot, and
everything in between. How
can you, as a product person, connect all of
that? It will even help you climb the career ladder, you
know? Because the higher you
climb in your product career, the
closer you get to executive positions. And
in executive positions, we
talk about this all the time, right? You're
speaking the language of the business, not
just the language of the product anymore.
The language of the business will be 90% of the
time about how to increase
revenue or how to reduce costs,
trying to simplify as much as possible, but without
wanting to oversimplify.
So, the more you can
speak in that language, the more you'll be
able to do impact analyses
of your product. That's
it. How do you do these analyses?
How do you
communicate this with other areas? Because a
large part of the other areas, as we've already
talked about in three episodes here, also
speak this language. And then...  Sometimes it's like, "
Oh, other areas are
generally biased towards technology" because people are
more concerned with talking about the story
points of the Sprint.
How many bi-weekly Sprints are about
Discovery and such, and less
about the end game in the end, right?
These things aren't
unimportant, but the discussion about them
is less important than
actually reducing costs and increasing
revenue. Ultimately, what
you're building is what
you're building, you know?
What will it become later? People are
more used to this, and sometimes
we forget, right? We live in a
tech bubble. Product development sometimes ends up isolated from the
rest of the company in that sense.
Operations is there talking about
direct costs, product technology, which is research, right? We're
not connecting what
they're doing with the
company's processes. So, if you want to start
using this in your company, in your team, here's something I
think is worth recommending
first: the first round—the
first rounds will always be a back-of-the-
envelope calculation—you'll assume a lot of
numbers, and okay, provided it's agreed upon
with the other areas and whoever is
going to...  I'm looking at this... I suffered a lot with
this, you know? I was... I was coming from
data, I really wanted to have the most
precise number possible, and also a lot of hammering
until I said, "No, not against the baker's rule,
most of the time it's
going to be Guren there, you know, exactly," and because it doesn't make sense for one team to use one number for the same thing and another team to use a different one, and neither of them does it, it won't make sense. To give an example, at Loft, when we started,
we called it Dollar Impact,
and for some specific initiatives
there, we were going to implement a new type
of house, right? We only had
apartments in the first Loft, and then we
took, as a
premise, the average ticket price that we
kind of had, like, PR houses and
everything else, but we assumed it was
exactly that, but that
helped us to have a benchmark
for all the teams to speak the same
language, and then we tuned it when
we actually saw that being the
delivery of that, in fact, right? So that's it,
assume the benchmarks and align them.  The
benchmark will remain the same, and then it's a matter of iteration; there's
no way around it because
the first few guesses will probably
be too high, but with each
round you'll fine-tune it. The good thing is to
do the before and after precisely so
you have that, right? We thought it would have such a big
impact, but in reality, it had
such a big impact. We were
too pessimistic, too
realistic, or perhaps too optimistic.
So, that will help you
set the benchmark for the next round, right? And it will
give you that repertoire and that tuning,
right? In the end, I think that
as a product person, every time I
talk about problem-
solving and the analytical part, I think the
most important part was learning by
doing. The iteration, so I don't want
you to take this problem, break it down,
structure it alone. I want you to
do it, then we'll talk together, and
we'll iterate, and we'll
talk to other people, and then you
'll go back and reorganize and
restructure. So, it's not something
that I'm going to do right away.  And it has to
be 100% right because there's
no such thing as absolute certainty here. Maybe up to a certain
level it exists, but you
can easily break the
levers so they don't overlap. There
comes a point where, you
know, it stops being productive
and becomes counterproductive. And then it depends a
lot on people's judgment.
If you can do that judgment
together with people who have experience, that's the
best way to learn. That's it. Well, we've
talked a lot, right? We have
tips and recommendations for those who
want to delve deeper into this subject, in addition
to taking the courses, which we'll
leave the dates for here. I have
some things here, so go ahead and talk about it.
First, I think
we can leave the link in the
episode. I said I have a document from
when I had to study,
and I can make it available. It's
nothing more than interesting links
that I found and that helped me
structure things here. So, you'll see that when you
open this document, there's a lot of
consulting content. As I said,
strategic consulting professionals are
trained to do this in a
structured way, so look for material from a
15 BCG company that...  There's quite a lot more to it than
that, I think we
also talked a lot about systems, right Artur?
I think there's a good book about that called
Thinking in Systems. I don't know
if it has a Portuguese version, I read it in
English, but if there is, we'll leave the link
here too. After you read it, you
'll see the Matrix in the world and how
everything is basically a system. And
lastly, on my side here, a little recommendation
for a website/tool ​​that
I think we've already talked about, which is
antus.co. It has a list of
frameworks for problem-solving and
decision-making, which sometimes you have
something in hand and you want
something to start
structuring. Go to antus and see
what best fits. That already
gives you a direction. And I think the chat is in Portuguese, which
we talked about here, I think it's
also good to have these interactions and
conversations, it can be a way for
you to ramp up as well. Artur, there are things
there, man, I think we've already talked about it, I
'll try to compile a little,
condense what we talked about
earlier, I think.  One of us has the other
book, which is Thinking Things,
we've already talked about it in some episodes
here, right? We've even discussed it; there's
even an episode of
Len's podcast that we always recommend
here with Duke, who is the author of the
book, and she talks a lot about
these processes. So I think what
I said above is relevant
too.
Math exercises can also help with
this, and studying a little
about correlation versus
causation is also a very
relevant point that makes sense. And the other one
you mentioned, and just to
wrap things up here, is a curiosity, right? A
curiosity about an exercise that
I love to do,
and it can be for anything, for example, "
Oh, I want to map a product,
map the events I would have
in a product, like, what product do I
use most here? Oh, I'll take it here and
do it backwards." Okay,
imagine the PM of this part here, what
event would be good, what do
I
analyze? But I'm giving this example
so that it doesn't become
tedious, and at a certain
point it will be... okay, even to leave...  Of course, it's
not always going to be easy, but
like, the products you like, analyze
how they make money, what are
the important metrics for them
to achieve that, and how is that
process structured? How do you think
the company is structured to reach
those points? It's super simple, but
you'll keep practicing. And then you use
APT charts or get
investor letters from companies that
are also publicly traded. I was going to say this,
man, every publicly traded company has to
disclose its results
quarterly, and you can go there, it's
open, so pick companies that are related
to the sector you work in or the sector
you're interested in. Another thing
I also did, which I think is interesting,
is to read the S1s, which are the documents that
companies going public need to
fill out. Basically, the S1 is
a huge paper, a
gigantic document, but it's a great
explanation of the business, basically
the company explaining to the market what that
business is, the story, all the
results so far, what thesis
they expect going forward. So,
for startups, that's a lot.  People
are interested, right? Getting the S1 and seeing it,
and all that explanation is also a
really cool thing for you to go deeper
into understanding the business. And of course,
to finish, you can choose how
you want to learn with us. There
will also be an online and live course
on June 29th and an in-person course on
July 6th. So, there you go, both will be on a Saturday,
a whole day for us to talk a
lot about just that. That's it. Now let's talk about
the products of the week. Let's go!
[Music]
The product of the week was a calculator because
of... Oh, it's
tough! Oh, oh, let's start, what's your
product of the week, my dear? No, you
're asking me to start because you haven't
put yours here yet, right? You're a
rascal! Look, man,
I'll tell you, I've been working a lot
these last few weeks, right? I think
within the "working a lot" I
spent a good part of my time in
spreadsheets, man, so I think Google
Sheets, because we have a
tool that's internal to Hotm, the
data tool is called AstroBox, so
I based a lot of time in AstroBox.
But that's only internal, and the
external tool...  What I used a lot was Google
Sheets, a whole lot, and just to mention something
we didn't talk about
this week, but
along with GPT 4, the company that launched
Open also made improvements to the
data analysis part of the GPT chat. And now
you can connect directly to
documents from Google Drive or
OneDrive, and it's a
much better data analyst. There's a post about it on the
Open website, so now the GPT
chat opens and you can interact with it from
within the chat. It's much more
interactive, it seems. I haven't tested it
very thoroughly yet, it was released to me
today, and man, it can be a
huge help for data analysis, even more than it
already was. So I'll test
it and bring news in the coming weeks.
Look, look,
but I'm on the same page as in the
last few weeks,
the modern worker,
the spreadsheet
and
PPT. I'm very happy that in the modern worker we
have a culture of more
written documents and less PPT. I hate making PPT,
man, but to condense
information, I...  I think PowerPoint is easier
than
old text, and I also like
written text and all that, but this way...
I used it a lot, and it's like
a universal language, right?
PowerPoint, and there's
also something we've
talked about in other episodes here, the issue
of how concise your
message is, because a slide forces you
to condense the information and do this
kind of synthesis or summary, when
necessary, with bullet points and all that, but it has to be
practical, right? So make slides
with a million things, font size 11,
five different graphs, three arrows, a
paragraph, like you said, a slide has to be
concise,
right? We're really hardworking, man. Let's
see if our listeners
brought more interesting apps than
ours. Well, they did!
Pilão sent the Drink Water app, which is
to track your water intake. I
have another one, I use a water app too,
which I think I even mentioned in an
episode here, let me see what it's
called. I drink a lot of water, I don't need
PR, I drink a lot, but...  I
like it because, well, I like to measure
things a lot, so I have it on my
watch or app on the main screen.
Every time I finish drinking
water, I go there and "boom" another
500ml, another 350ml, which is the drink. What I use
is Waterminder, but what Pilon
sent is the Water Drink app. Natasha sent
Late Driver, which
she uses
in the interior of São Paulo state, and I'll even tell you exactly what
she
said. She has it in the interior of São
Paulo and it has some bugs, but it
works better and she trusts it more
than Uber.
Daniela sent Brawl Stars, the little
game, and Beola sent
ClassPass, which he said, even though it
seems a little more expensive than... what's
the new name of the app? You
know what's funny? The
icon changed to Well Hub, but the app's name on
the phone is still... which I thought was
an excellent idea because when I
go to search here to check my name,
I don't remember what it is. It already starts
lying down.  In terms of footsteps, and I think it's
an ASO strategy, right? App Store
optimization, and wow, it reminded me of my
mobile days. But anyway, there are
several options and several
cool things there. Oh, and that's it,
keep sending it to
[Music]
guys, and with that, we end
today's program, right? Once again, here are the
usual reminders. Follow us on
your favorite podcast player:
Spotify, YouTube,
Substack, anywhere you listen to
podcasts. If you liked this
week's discussion or any other episode,
recommend it. Send it to a friend,
to a coworker.
Tell them to listen to an episode of Papo na Arena, they
can watch it on YouTube. Zero
friction, no need to download a
podcast or anything like that, so recommend it. It really
helps the
podcast grow and reach more people.
And follow us on social media, right? Instagram,
Twitter, LinkedIn, I'm @x
everywhere. Artur is @arthur.
Close with, and our home is @productArena, where
we're always doing things.
Product of the week polls,
promoting the episodes, reposting
when you send them in, tagging us, right? Listen
on the podcast, so do that too, and
we'll repost it there. And next week there's
more, that's it, next week we're
back
and we'll see you at the arena, that's it, thanks, thanks.